bah ça tourne comme l'instant je leur
fais pas un jour ce qu'il ya quelques
uns d'entre eux qui commencent un petit
peu à nous dire des choses en europe
donc on va bien voir comment ça non mais
je je je les connais pas suffisamment
mon nom nadir marque donc nous notre
objectif je vous le dis très franchement
ça va être décidé en convaincre une
certaine partie de modifier le rail
parce que nous savons que certains ont
été investis et sont pas forcément tous
alignés derrière la pensée nouvelle
macro mais pour l'instant je dois
constater que dans les débats
on va dire c'est une majorité godillot
voilà qui applaudit quand on lui demande
les questions le jour à l'assemblée vous
utilisez regarder à une exception près
du côté la polynésie s'il n'ya compris
de de la présentant la polynésie je me
trompe je crois les autres c'était des
questions cireurs de pompes quoi enfin
franchement c'était une manière de dire
au gouvernement de deux des laquais
l'occasion gouvernement de de vanter son
son sens son bilan bon voilà